non ce la faccio
peggio
dice la moglie
non ce la faccio o no stare cioè se no
troppo belli e un posto di sincero mi
dispiace non posso recensirlo non so
cosa dire talmente inutile che posso
posso dire mi dispiace di ottobre ma non
posso aiutarti e no no no no devi
farcela con le due forze
mi dispiace ma il giovane grazie
bastardo
eccovi la recensione di
troppo belli
già con i numeri
numero 5 da un'idea di maurizio costanzo
non ci sarebbe molto da commentare è
un'idea di maurizio costanzo maurizio
costanzo e un uomo che era iscritto alla
p2 alla b2 se non sapete cos'è andate a
vedere che cos'è la p2 ha anche
intervistato licio gelli
se non sapete chi è dice gelli andate a
controllare non dico altro andate a
controllare
numero 4 fuori posto
sono io oppure
costantino vitaliano e daniele
interrante
che dio li fulmini sono sempre fuori
posto in ogni scena c'è almeno questo è
quello che ho notato io gli attori e gli
altri attori del film sono diciamo
decenti ci provengono già da fiction
della mediaset della rai eccetera ma
loro che non sono attori non sono
persone non solo umanoidi fanno schifo
ma non solo recitare proprio a trovarsi
lì ad essere anche quello che sono nei
nel film ci sono due ragazzi qualunque
teoricamente non riescono neanche ad
essere ragazzi con lunghe sembrano
immagini spiaccicate nella pellicola con
photoshop che non c'entrano
assolutamente nulla con quello che
stanno facendo infatti ogni volta che
c'è una loro scena loro ci sembra che la
loro mente si svuoti anzi ve lo posso
mostrare veniamo ai raggi ics più o meno
cosa ci potrebbe essere dentro la testa
di daniele e cosa ci potrebbe essere
dentro la testa di costantino secondo
voi mi ami me mi ami ami me mi hanno in
mano
non avevo dubbi
numero 3
la trama io
questo film è molto
inutile
molto
questo vuol dire che ho trovato ci ho
avuto veramente tanta difficoltà
a scrivere i cinque punti e soprattutto
a guardarlo tutto questo film è la prima
volta che non riesco a guardare un film
trash tutto ma perché la trama è
praticamente inesistente c'è ripeto è
inutile questo film quindi è difficile
capire e difficile difficile capire cosa
commentare e cosa non commentare senza
balbettare però la trama è completamente
inesistente c'è spesso la trama come
abbiamo visto in avatar può essere
semplice per tirare su un buon film no
qua no qua no qua no e come se ogni
volta ogni scena cercassero di tirare la
corda per arrivare fino alla fine c'è
dai che ce la fai in questa scena se
qualcosa non lavorano tra ma c'è
qualcosa o almeno proviamo alla prossima
loro che tentano di fare un provino come
attori perché ce la fai qualcosa qualche
diavolo importante no qualcosa che vada
avanti con la trova niente dai che ce la
fai venuto a caccia la faccia la puoi
fare in questa scena niente questo
niente resta niente niente niente
aiuto la
pronto come faccio a fare una decisione
di un film del genere è inutile non è
brutto non è bello è inutile cioè come
sparare sulla croce rossa come
lanciarazzi
stai recensendo troppo belli non scusa
però non ho fatti tuoi cioè io ne voglio
sapere niente proprio sì ho capito la
sono fatti tuoi
teoricamente la
tra molte file di virgolette trama
sarebbe che loro due sono dei figli
paura può più paura e panico
che tentano di entrare nel mondo del
cinema e vengono truffati
fine c'è come teoricamente quello che
sarebbe dovuto succedere nella realtà no
ovviamente li hanno presi per forza
numero due
com'è possibile anche se la trama è
praticamente inesistente ovviamente
dentro ci sono tante di quelle puttanate
da fare invidia a robot olocausti tutti
quelli che ho recensito prima c'è chi
l'ha visto pensione attimo al contesto
c'è questi due ragazzi sono conosciuti
da tutta italia riff il medico sono
conosciuti da tutti tale tutela ragazzi
che si strappano i capelli litigano
appena li vedono sono troppo belli
troppo belli troppo belli ma loro
lavorano ci fanno lavori saltuari e il
vero do con i genitori
non che ci sia nulla di male ma come
cazzo fanno tutti a conoscerli se loro
non è che lavorano in tv nel film ripeto
non lavorano in tv o non sono famosi
sono solo belli ma comunque come è
possibile che tutte le ragazzine li
conosco e ne abbiano foto di loro
illumina le mutande sappiano dove
abitano eccetera non è possibile è il
bracco enorme del film c'è che non se ne
sono accorti se poi ci sono certe scene
che ho annunciato di pensare lasciati
qui costantino e la ragazza si mollano
dopo un bel po di tempo che stavano
insieme mi sembra che non lo dica ma
comunque erano da un bel po di tempo
insieme un secondo dopo che si mollano
la ragazza esce come un loro amico ma se
con dopo è un amico normale vanno a cena
insieme
e un secondo dopo che sono usciti
insieme si sono messi insieme no c'è non
è possibile fisicamente una cosa del
genere perché passa troppo poco tempo
per crederci se non le possiamo infatti
vi dico ma forse gli sta dicendo questo
per farlo ingelosire per farlo tornare
con sé no c'è boh io non lo so ma fate
voi è irrealistico da fare paura
nonostante sia un film che teoricamente
dovrebbe essere realistico mi fa schifo
una cosa del genere non puoi non
pensarci perché non è non è una fantasia
significa è una cosa semplicissima da
mettere a posto quella no non riescono a
fare neanche quello c'è tanto vale che
si sposino pure potrai mai venga meno
già fatta davvero sì e per dimostrartelo
mi piacerebbe che facessi da testimone
al mio matrimonio
un matrimonio non è possibile
dopo due secondi che si sono mollati già
si sono messi d'accordo con ciò amico di
sposarsi per sposarsi
ok bellissima anche la scena dove
costantino per cercare di intrufolarsi
nel mondo del lavoro nel cinema nello
spettacolo si fa una sveltina con la
produttrice in una specie di camerino
[Musica]
bene bravi ce ne sono sono convinto che
questa sia l'unica parte realistica del
firmware che siccome è successo
esattamente così ciechi costantini
daniele siano andati con il produttore
del film siano dati a letto con il
produttore del film riuscire a farlo suo
film e vi ricordo che il produttore del
film e maurizio costanzo
numero uno troppo belli questo punto va
oltre l'abominevole è proprio l'idea il
concetto sbagliato ma sbagliato
sbagliato c'è chi poi dicono e l'italia
va a rotoli sì ma questo è uno dei
motivi che io allora
costantini daniele sono due due ex
tronisti di nuovo come come karim
capuano detto l'orco
cosa dire delle ne sono due ex tronisti
e sono riusciti a fare un film
nonostante loro non sappiamo recitare
c'è ma io mi chiedo ma come possono
sentirsi gli attori veri gli attori veri
quelli che che ci sono attori ma che non
sono teoricamente ancora diventati a 13
e quegli attori di teatro che si fanno
un culo così dalla mattina alla sera per
essere bravissimi a teatro che nessuno
li guarda e sono sottopagati ma sono
bravissimi quando vedono questi due
pezzi di merda che vanno a lavorare e
vengono pagati un sacco solo perché sono
belli
ripeto piano piano per chi di voi non ha
ancora capito
loro hanno fatto un film solo leggetela
viale perché sono belli e sbagliato
concettualmente sbagliato questo è
l'oblio è l'oblio dell'italia questo
film
alex l'ariete parentesi tonde sono
capolavori da oscar lo seppe detto
bastardo tu che me l'hai passato
bastardi hicks che è riuscito a passarmi
con
bastardo vedere nel film ragazzine che
rubano le loro mutande che comprano a 30
50 euro le loro foto
che anche loro hanno un enorme buco nero
nel cervello non importa chi esclude la
testa
[Applauso]
l'uno non quella scena non ti prego no
ma non a quella cena lodi per una di
notte soldi che votino la ragazza ti do
la mia casa il mio che ha vinto tutto
quello che non amate per con quella
scena no
[Applauso]
pronto a lui e la mamma
[Musica]